well I never thought I'd see Kurt
Russell in Alaska again anyone messes
with me and the whole Camp
goes Monarch episode 4 is here with a
ton of new questions and theories on
what's going on in the monsterverse for
those of you new to these videos this is
not a recap but a deep dive into the
mysteries of the show and I've left
timestamps below so you can see all the
topics I'll be covering and before we
get into it make sure to like And
subscribe I'm planning on covering every
episode of the Season all the way out in
Utah we have Monarch Outpost 47 in king
of the monsters we learn that Monarch
has over 230 such outposts scattered all
over the world stationed here is a woman
known only as Barnes who any of the boys
fans out there might remember as hu's
girlfriend in episode 1 it's currently
unknown if there's any relation between
her and Soldier Jackson Barnes from king
of the monsters the legendary Twitter
account posted this Monarch activation
dossier which shows that he has a sister
named Stephanie Barnes here seems to be
the only only scientist at this remote
Utah Outpost which charmingly has
Armageddon energy drinks littered
throughout the place things take a
dramatic turn when Barnes picks up
strange pulses of gamma radiation
similar to the readings Monarch received
shortly before Godzilla attacked San
Francisco on gday this puts assistant
director of Monarch Natalie Verdugo in a
difficult position does she warn the
world that an attack may be imminent
causing panic or does monarch take
matters into its own hands and try to
stop this attack before it happens there
seems to be two factions within Monarch
one run by this military woman who wants
to attack and the other by Tim who wants
to study and learn from these Titans so
expect this conflict to continue in the
episodes to come last episode we got our
first glimpse of a new Titan called the
frost Fark and in episode four we learn
a bit more about how it operates the
frost bark is attracted to heat which
Lee Shaw and the others will use to
their advantage to make make their
escape but what intrigues me the most
about these Titans is what Lee Shaw says
Ah Titans have odd effects on their
surroundings and how we experience them
if we're to believe Lee it was the Titan
energy that messed up their electrical
instruments we also see that Kate May
and Lee end up walking around in circles
and canaro experiences hallucinations so
it BS the question to what extent can
these Titans manipulate our surroundings
what other weird and strange effects can
they inflict on us humans Barnes tells
us that the readings she's picked up are
common from pulsars originating from
black holes in outer space the pulses
she's picking up however are coming from
Earth specifically Alaska could this
then mean that this swirling light we
see emanating From Below is the cause of
these readings a pulsar emits
electromagnetic radiation and we know
that Titans are attracted to radiation
so there seems to be a link here
readings of this kind haven't been seen
since gingira and Yuka Flats gingira was
where the nuclear power plant a male
mudo fed off in 2014's Godzilla and Yuka
Flats was where the female mudo fed off
discarded nuclear waste this episode
offers us a little more insight into
karo's past particularly his foray into
the art world I think it's pretty
interesting that his work centers around
challenging our assumptions about
identity pretty ironic since his own
identity is called into question after
finding out his father had a secret
second family canaro doesn't have an
answer as to why he makes this type of
art calling it intuitive and that's
likely because he's struggling with
finding out his own identity this is
where canaro meets May and I don't know
about you guys but I think she's
definitely hiding something not only did
she initially upload those secret files
without telling canaro but last episode
we saw her throw a phone into the ocean
totally normal behavior and things get
even more suspicious this episode when
they land it's May who's adamant that
canaro didn't see this abandon an
outpost even though he said he did in
episode 3 what's that down there then
there's this line people don't give
other people a shot unless they're
something in it for them did may give
canaro a shot because there was
something in it for her when Ken asks
her what her job is she's extremely
vague stating computer she has a
bag full of passports and money and to
top it off we see her phone is a flip
phone ancient Tech even by 2015
standards you'd think someone whose job
is computers would be a little more up
to date even when may is on the brink of
death she won't let Lee take her bag
come on May let me carry that bag St no
it's almost as if there's something in
there she doesn't want him to see we
also get the name of May's sister lra
who she tells to stop calling because
she's busy traveling for work the fact
we never see her is also suspicious and
I wonder if this person could be someone
we already know Cano's discovery of the
abandoned Outpost brings hope to Ken and
Kate that their father is still alive
the pile of pencil shavings something
Hiroshi would carve and a working radio
suggest their father had fixed it and
radioed for help just who picked them up
and where he went remains to be seen it
should also be noted that all of
hiroshi's files seem to have been
destroyed this episode his notes from
the tent were used to fuel the fire and
the computer with the digital files were
frozen by the Titan so it looks as
though our characters are back to square
one but something tells me Tim and
Monarch may offer them some Clues now we
get into to the trailer soothing part of
the video where we take a look at the
season's trailers to see what could be
coming next keep in mind I won't be
covering every shot just the ones I
think will be relevant in the episodes
to come here we see Lee Shaw tied up
with a film reel playing behind him it
looks to be the Philippines 1952 reel
Ken found in his father's office I'm
inclined to believe that Lee gets
separated from Ken Kate and may as we'll
later see them on their own being given
a tour of the Monarch Arlington
headquarters without him it appears as
though Lee is interrogated by Natalia
Verdugo judging by This Woman's hair in
the back if you've seen my previous
videos you'll know I've theorized that
Lee Shaw and Koo had an affair and it's
possible he's hiroshi's father making
Kate and canaro his grandchildren there
are quite a few shots of Le and Koo
together we haven't seen yet including
this one of them dancing this is the
only shot of Hiroshi we haven't seen yet
however we can't be sure if this is a
flashback or not this metal sphere in
the background could be some sort of
scientific EXP experiment he also seems
to be in a desert of sorts and
considering we'll see our main cast in a
desert setting I can't help but think
there's a connection take a look at
these two shots one is from the first
trailer and the other from the second
but look at the difference in the
mountain in the background either the
VFX team put this in as a set extension
or this could be Godzilla's spine check
out this aerial shot of a spiky mountain
range crumbling and the emergence of
Godzilla although there's no definitive
proof yet that hosi is here when Kate
and canaro are this is something I'm
really interested in Lee sha going into
this large sphere almost as if he's some
sort of astronaut my best guess is that
this is a mission to the hollow Earth
the home of the Titans we saw in
Godzilla versus Kong we'll see a similar
if not the same sphere over 50 years
later in the background of this image
here's Ken matching up some pinpoints of
light to coordinates from a map that
looks a lot like the one found in his
father's office it's possible it could
lead to one of the geoc coordinates May
found while scanning Monarch's files and
Lee here in front of a computer that
says primed when I think of primed I
think of a bomb so who knows what he's
up to but now I turn it over to you what
do you think will happen in the episodes
to come I want to hear your thoughts and
theories in the comments below thanks
for watching please be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
Daddy loves you very
much